here's the hard place you find yourself
you're going to have to sit down to a
man that you love that you've spent
probably more time with him in your life
than you have without him is that
fair yes and you're going to have to say
I haven't told you the truth for about
30 years it will be
devastating one because he's hurt you
for so long he didn't know he
was two the dishonesty this is going to
be a hard hard
path his world will be uneven he won't
be able to stand on the foundation that
he thought his life was and in a weird
way it'll be such a great relief but
when you do this have this conversation
you're gonna have to be
specific about what has to happen in
this new marriage you'll have to build
because you're not going backwards to
when y'all were dating you're going to
have to decide we're going to build
something totally new and that's where
you have to be specific in this new
marriage here's what romance feels and
looks like to me